[Música]
[Aplausos]
nena me rompí el cuello
aun cuando mi hermano se está a punto de
morir trata de protegerme para que no me
asustará a partir de ahí mi vida cambió
completamente desde que era pequeña me
han encantado las historias de princesas
siempre creía que había un final feliz
para todos que algún día iba a encontrar
mi príncipe azul y que siempre iba a
haber alguien ahí para protegerme mi
hermano
desde que éramos pequeños hemos sido
super unidos aunque sea seis años mayor
que yo cuando estábamos en primaria
siempre le iba a pedir ayuda porque
tenía muchos problemas recuerdo mucho
que un día estaba llorando como
magdalena y de repente fui a ver a mi
hermana que está jugando fútbol me pare
afuera de la cancha de fútbol
mi hermano albert me corrió para su
partido entero y me dijo no a na estás
bien que te pasa yo yo hablando nada más
le podía decir alan es que me dijeron
cada de piña y obviamente me odio como
nunca en ese momento pero lo único que
hizo fue respirar hondo aquella perote
que acabe mi partido y voy a verte y así
fue acabó su partido
vino a verme se paró a mi lado en frente
de esa persona que me había dicho a la
cara de piña y le dijo no le digas estas
cosas a mi hermana
de repente me encontraba en ese sueño
eterna de la bella durmiente' donde me
sentía protegida
me sentí amada me sentía feliz
hasta que desperté en una realidad
inmediata y dolorosa donde me sentía
completamente sola solo quería seguir
soñando un poquito más no salirme de mi
burbuja
hace casi cuatro años sufrimos un
accidente automovilístico en el cual mi
hermano queda en silla de ruedas no
recuerdo mucho del accidente la verdad
creo que mi mente bloqueó tales
recuerdos para mi propio bien recuerdo
ambulancia recuerdo policías recuerdo
sangre recuerdo mi papá abrazándome
tranquila mi niña todo va a estar bien
de repente estaba en la sala de
emergencias frente al cuerpo debilitado
de mi hermano diciéndome nena me rompió
el cuello
obviamente sentí muchísimo dolor en ese
momento ver a mi protector ver a mi
ídolo mi hermano mayor tan débil
pero aún así tenía mi familia apoyándome
y protegiendo me aún así con 14 años lo
único que podía pensar con muchísima
culpa fuera porque no me pasó a mí
mi hermano ya viviendo solo ya formando
una vida teniendo tantas historias que
contar en comparación con migo que
apenas estaba empezando a crecer que no
importaba lo que me queda por vivir que
era más inmadura por ser más pequeña no
me parecía justo sentía muchísima culpa
pero poco a poco después de un año de
rehabilitación viendo a mi hermano
mejorar pasito a pasito y yo con el de
la mano mejoramos juntos
en algún momento me dijo mi hermana mi
hija lonas es que me voy del df para
estudiar la universidad con mi ama
nunca llegué a pensar todo lo que me iba
nunca llegue a pensar a imaginar todo lo
que me va a pasar a penas teniendo 15
años tenía muchísima libertad ya no
estaba esa persona tras de mí diciéndome
lana esta tarea la habana a su cama
recoge tu cuerdo no pierdas el tope que
en parte estaba muy bien
pero también me sentía muy sola muy
frustrada y muy enojada con la vida
estaba desesperadamente tratando de
buscar llenar ese vacío hasta que de un
día a otro conocí a alguien me hizo
sentir feliz me hizo sentir amada me
hizo sentir protegida como dice una
canción todo inició es hermoso que es
muy cierto y así fue
pero nada es para siempre entro en una
relación muy tóxica en la cual no me
sentía bien conmigo misma manipulaba
esta persona bastante diciéndome no
bailes así no te vistas así no hables
con tal persona no uses de excusa a tu
hermano la que está mal eres tú
y de repente volteaba y ya no estaba mi
hermano mayor ahí para decirle oye no le
digas esas cosas a mi hermana yo misma
tenía que protegerme pero deje que todo
lo que me dijera me definiera pensaba
que la que estaba mal era yo y no le
decía nada por miedo a que exactamente a
quedarme sola
no quería nunca pisé nunca quise pedir
ayuda porque no quise mostrar ese lado
de mí quería mostrarme fuerte y valiente
como mi hermano siempre lo ha sido el
punto es que terminamos pero aún así
deje que todo lo que me había dicho me
persiguiera cada día
después tuve la fortuna de irme a vivir
un año con mi mamá y con mi hermano al
principio sentía que no había nada bueno
en esta vida me sentía muy débil
hasta que me reencontré con lo que más
amo y me vuelve loca volvía a bailar
de repente me empezó a gustar más y más
como bailaba me empecé a sentir más
segura de mí misma me sentía en parte
también más flaca y empecé a amar a mí
misma cada paso significaba algo
expresaba aquello que no podía decir con
palabras el baile me regreso esa parte
de mí que creía haber perdido me
fortalecí por medio de este arte y forje
es mi personalidad sin necesidad de
tener a mis papás a mi lado todo el
tiempo poco a poco fui mejorando conocí
a alguien que me hizo ver las cosas de
forma diferente me hizo entender que hay
gente buena y que lo único que necesito
es alguien que sea comprensivo y atento
crecer da miedo y más cuando no tenemos
a alguien que nos protege a nuestro lado
después de varios años la vida me dio la
oportunidad de mejorar y entendí que
debo de darme esa oportunidad de crecer
enfrentando mis miedos entendí que lo
que le había pasado a mi hermano no era
mi culpa pero sí mi responsabilidad
salir adelante entendí que mi familia es
mi centro es mi felicidad es mi
equilibrio tenía que aprovecharla y
también que nuestros padres siempre
quieren forjar nuestra personalidad pero
no tenerlos tenemos la oportunidad de
hacerlo nosotros mismos entendí que la
vida sigue sea como sea que hay que
estar ocupados mental y físicamente que
nada es para siempre y todo todo tiene
solución y que también se vale estar mal
que se vale llorar porque es
completamente normal y humano nadie
puede estar feliz las 24 horas del día
imagínense es que miedo
pero bueno también entendí que si yo no
me amaba nadie más me iba a amar que si
yo no me protegía ni me cuidaba nadie
más lo iba a ser por mí y que tampoco
estaba del todo sola que si estaba mal
tenía que pedir ayuda lo que quiero
decirle a todos ustedes soy de verdad
estar aquí es todo un reto para mí pero
solo quiero decirles que hay que confiar
en uno mismo para salir adelante porque
cada quien tiene esa fuerza y también un
poquito ayuda extra jamás hace mal hay
que saber que no estamos del todo solos
que hay gente muy buena y dispuesta a
ayudar y bueno después de todos estos
años de confusión dolor de mucha
felicidad y muchísimo crecimiento
entendí algo
y luego me di cuenta que albert einstein
ya lo había dicho entonces los dejo con
esta frase
efe lights opportunity muchas gracias
[Aplausos]